I like cupcakes
without my child yeah four or five
campaign listening the new roster yeah
these these are my favorite you know may
Allah reward this brother you know why
because we actually agreed on five but
then I sent him six images just to see
if you would you know honey and he
actually came of six he's a big guy he's
chose the big sweets stony solid okay
right now we are picking up one of the
batches of cakes made by one of the
sisters mail of lesser thank you so much
okay so as you can see brothers and
sisters right now we have Ali holding
some of the cakes masha'Allah second
location Ali what are those what those
shoes hashtag I mean slash tag do you
guys this guy literally just bought us
to the wrong place yeah and made us
stand outside some random person's house
yes that's a very good idea ID I'm proud
of you we've got what we need you for
making we gonna have to try some of the
salvage these cakes yes make sure that
yes you know just to market research
thank you selling them okay honey while
we doing here could you tell us please
aloma bike see only only any masala
sound into this can you tell us what
that means mushed it heavenly bites by
me son just trying to fit the cakes into
the car on to the next destination we're
picking up some cakes from these guys in
sha Allah we're moving weight thank you
so much money do you use my guys so
we're basically Riley's yard just
loading yeah cause before you know what
we want what the cakes they stay fresh
so we have loaded the stuff into these
car tomorrow
the next step is going to Leicester
Square unloading this stuff saying up
the gazebo and giving these cakes out
see you guys
laughing what's on your maternity
Baruchel
Vanetta
Pleiades so honey level feed the power
Vicki Donovan and cheddar hiya for
always fun Danny right now we're
basically setting up a cake stands
you're gonna be given up we still need
to put the stickers on them and so that
at least panicking so
more than people with Micah's Dhoni
Vidia the paper boy barbecue
there you go thank you
it's very good thank you
yeah
you know
I try to put you sensitive guys I don't
see any animal feed
Piketty fellow from the van and cheddar
hiya for obvious wondering why enjoy
knowing the paper yeah for you is free
3k alive saw it in your eyes you want to
make I know you guys what can I say man
a llama bearing such a beautiful way to
give dollar because people remember a
good gesture you given up cake we wanna
show Kenny
Sheikh Mohammed's wife may do deals yes
but now we've got me cheesecake there
these are the best ones mommy gave me
what
and to treatment whether or won't both
of them reach old age while with your
state knocks them so Anessa and do not
repel them but speak to them in an
overworld we got this gazebo
oh my
good wage okay so basically work on
things before you know you know we live
in a time where people what's the best
way possible without you know something
indicate
the sharing of light appears
like Jeff said no compassion now we have
to exemplify Islam for action than
nothing
today's a bit of that so yeah so you
know brothers and sisters in the past
we've all you know been in different
places trying to give now we've never
done this as muhammad is ever said and
it was an amazing thing to do because
literally people are flocking to us
taking these cards taking the cake that
specifically if they've left the card
man picking the card up reading the card
I literally saw someone standing there
just reading the card and pondering on
it it's so so powerful and we need to
continue doing this we need to think of
new ways to give our and it's absolutely
beautiful but you got natural cakes it
works some brothers and sisters we need
your support to keep this going
insha'Allah we aim to do this on a
monthly basis and inshallah once we've
got that going on there even more
regular basis we want to make this
something regular our next objective is
going to actually sneak a home and mind
those people no gives their their you
know one of our messages on here in the
Quran Sunnah said that when you reach
old age your parents here so you see off
to them and so Ali you know one thing I
wanted to mention to the people here
because they've seen us giving Dawa yeah
what's new about this world problem
sisters we've come together and we've
made an organized fashion of giving
dollar now we're going to be doing this
on a regular basis as a team together in
a project in an organized way I'm gonna
give a gift to Muhammad he job he's one
of our testers
as you know he takes his time if you
just want to zoom into his hand okay he
needs to have moisturizer house how to
take stuff is usually Bravo of toodles
so prevalent sisters Jessica Lowe Heron
we need your support to continue this
one of the main reasons why I feel like
this needs support is because all of us
myself problem harmony job I need our
multiple of us have come together and
we're doing this project on a long-term
basis we plan on doing this on a regular
basis every single month we need things
to be happening each other supports
Jessica now Karen for watching Salaam
alaikum o Allah